possesseur d'un poêle à granules vous
pensiez lier l'utile à l'agréable avec
un mode de chauffage efficace et bon
marché sauf que depuis un an c'est la
douche froide sous l'effet de
l'explosion de la demande le prix des
pellets a été multiplié par deux et
c'est le bois de chauffage qui tire son
épingle du jeu voyez ce reportage à La
Ville-aux-Dames et larset de Sébastien
brancher et Aurélie Renaud
Alain se chauffe au bois depuis toujours
cette année son stère de bois passe de
77 à 79 euros une hausse qu'il accepte
pourvu qu'il soit approvisionné en temps
et en heure on sent bien que si j'avais
été client pour la première fois
peut-être que disons là le monsieur
bourgeard m'a dit m'a demandé si j'étais
client déjà
livre du bois de chauffage depuis 30 ans
et cette année est inédite les commandes
sont multipliées par deux effectivement
de nouveaux clients arrivent leur
cheminée qui servait à faire des feux
d'agrément devient le principal
chauffage de la maison dans leur idée je
pense qu'elle est de faire baisser
baisser le cours le coût de la facture
énergétique et de deux on entend parler
de restriction de voilà ils savent que
ils ont ils préparent le plan B tout
simplement alors c'est sûr que ça donne
des tensions assez importantes
sur les commandes parce que nous on peut
pas livrer le double dans une journée un
chauffeur peut faire qu'un certain
nombre de livraisons dans sa journée
autre phénomène l'explosion des achats
de poêle à bois les fournisseurs de
granulés peinaient déjà à suivre la
demande mais avec la fin du fioul
domestique et la crainte de manquer des
pénuries apparaissent ici dans cette
grande enseigne la rareté a
considérablement fait augmenter le prix
des granulés aujourd'hui
la demande client est supérieure à
l'offre des fabricants ce qui fait que
les prix malheureusement ont augmenté et
on est passé en un an et demi d'un sac
de pellets qui coûtait 4,50 € à un sac
de pellets aujourd'hui qui dépasse 10
euros en France ce sont près de 7
millions de logements qui se chauffent
au bois l'objectif de l'État est de
porter ce chiffre à 9,5 millions de
logements en 2023